- I'M NOT HERE
TO MAKE FRIENDS.
- I AIN'T GONNA MAKE
ONE FRIEND.
- I'M JUST HERE TO WIN.
I'M NOT HERE TO MAKE FRIENDS.
- OKAY.
- NO.
YOU'RE HERE TO MAKE FRIENDS.
MAKING FRIENDS
IS THE NAME OF THIS SHOW.
- ♪ YOU AND ME FOREVER
- OKAY, I GOT TO LOOK OUT
FOR NUMBER ONE.
- OKAY, THAT'S NOT TRUE.
YOU WOULD LOSE IF YOU LOOK OUT
FOR NUMBER ONE.
- HEY, LOOK, DUDE,
THAT'S YOUR OPINION.
- DOES ANYBODY KNOW
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE?
- I LOCKED DOWN PLANS,
CHICKS, GUYS.
YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
THIS WAS A COMPETITION.
JUST SAW A SIGN
FOR MAKING FRIENDS
AND THOUGHT THAT WOULD
BE COOL.
- YOU SEE, THIS WOULD BE
A GOOD TIME TO MAKE A FRIEND.
- I'M JEFF, BY THE WAY.
JEFF.
- HOW ARE YOU?
- OH.
- JEFF.
HEY.
JEFF.
HOW ARE YOU?
- IF ANYONE WILL BE FRIENDS
WITH JEFF,
THEY WILL--
THEY WILL WIN A POINT.
- I'LL MAKE AN ALLIANCE
WITH JEFF.
- GREAT.
- BUT I WILL STAB HIM
IN THE BACK.
- THAT'S YOUR PREROGATIVE.
EITHER WAY, WE HAD A FRIENDSHIP.
- DOES ANYONE GO
FOR A LIGHT LUNCH WITH JEFF?
- CHICKEN SALAD.
- THIS NETWORK WILL GIVE YOU
1 MILLION CASH DOLLARS.
A LOT OF NOS.
- YEAH, WHAT ABOUT TAXES?
- I'LL PAY 'EM.
LOOK, LET ME JUST SAY,
YOU KNOW,
EVEN THOUGH
I GOT VOTED OFF FIRST,
I FEEL LIKE I MADE FRIENDS
FOR A LIFETIME.
- ♪ YOU AND ME FOREVER
- [whistling]